das österreichische bundesheer verfügt
mit der arbeitsgruppe über eine
spezielle einheit gegen die abwehr von
atomaren biologischen und chemischen
gefahren heute schauen wir uns aufgrund
der aktuellen lage in der ukraine
besonders die abwehr und dementsprechend
zeigen wir jetzt wie man radioaktiver
strahlung detektiert wir haben hier eine
oberfläche die möglicherweise
kontaminiert ist und mit diesem
arbeitsgerät den 190 indiz integration
sondern wird eben strahlung detektiert
wenn der dreifache leer wert
überschritten wird bekommt man an der
sonne ein akustisches signal und eine
anzeige gegen einen zahlenwert anzeigt
und wenn die strahlung festgestellt
worden ist dann gibt es nur drei
möglichkeiten abstand gewinnen die
arbeitszeit verringern oder abschirmen
auf dieser oberfläche wurde eine
radioaktive kontamination festgestellt
um diese zu entfernen müssen spezielle
die kontamination scam italien
aufgebracht werden
dazu ist wichtig zu sagen dass die
radioaktive strahlung natürlich nicht
zerstört wird sondern nur von der
oberfläche entfernt wird wenn das
dekorations mittel aufgebracht worden
ist muss das mit wasser entfernt werden
und damit wird die kontamination von der
platte gewaschen
nach der radioaktiven kontamination und
der dekontamination kann mit dem
messgerät überprüft werden ob die fläche
tatsächlich wieder sauber ist nach der
erfolgten dekontamination ist die da
sind die strahlenden partikel nicht
zerstört und jetzt ist die abgefangene
die koordinations flüssigkeit in
entsprechende gefährdung